no I don't think so I mean you know I
had this friend of mine he was a
congressman from West Virginia he he was
a man of faith it got beat after his
first term good guy Republican it's okay
but he he told me he went home and he
was such a man of faith he said I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna pray and I'm gonna
wait for God to give me the answer and
the direction he wants me to go now and
one year later he was still waiting the
point he made to be he said I finally
figured out I had to take the first step
pet take step I had to do something and
I think you know we can pray and and
sometimes it's it's not as clear to us
what it should be but sometimes you just
have to take that first step and they
just have to go on a direction that you
think you should go and you might not it
might not be as clear from God or maybe
you're not a person of faith I don't
know but you just have to you have to
take that step you have to talk to your
friends and just tell them what you're
thinking and then you can wait be
patient now obvious then one of these
days you're just going to take that step
you have to step out you're going to
have to and you know what you're gonna
have to be able for your head sometimes
you're over your head when you do these
things I completely agree with you I
think what I hope you might also
elaborate on is that those people out
there who are not in complete agreement
with you on that issue people who don't
recognize that obligation how do you
teach people that it's important as
opposed to for example go and do the
thing that you're most skilled at
don't you get to answer some of these
questions you're on the hot seat okay
i'll add to their questions I won't take
any way sure I don't know I need to
think a little bit more I don't have a
ready answer for you